Slavik is with us in a Sacramento hi
Slovak what's up hi Dave thank you for
taking my call about 13 months ago I
made a knife and posted it on YouTube
video and I hope you get a thousand
views later on the viewers start
commenting that this knife looks very
familiar or similar to a knife used in a
video game so I had an idea why don't I
make knives from the video games because
it became very popular my channel grew
from 12 subscribers to 60,000 to the
date and I monetize my videos I made a
separate checking account for YouTube
payments I keep track of money that I
spent for the tools and separately for
the material so my question is I live in
the apartment and my question is do I
need to make our license for the videos
and also after I make the knife I sell
it so if it's under $500 do I need to
report it as income also how do i how
many of these knives have you sold 12 so
far okay what do they sell for I see 120
currently the last one got sold for 450
Wow okay cool good for you thank you and
you're making you're making YouTube
income as well yes sir
how much um I started with $120 and
right now my last paycheck that I got
I'm 24 they stay on the point first of
each month it was $290 and right now
looking up their mind YouTube channel
earnings are above 420 and they're still
growing well good for you
way to go d okay no I wouldn't fool with
licensing this at this stage there's no
you're not in to make enough income but
before you pull the money out of your
separate account and start using it
personally you need to set aside some
for taxes usually about a
fourth of your profits will be pretty
close for your taxes and set that aside
in a separate checking account you need
to file quarterly estimates on your
business I give your business a name and
that you don't have to incorporate it or
anything you can just DBA it's Slovak
so-and-so DBA doing business as Slovaks
knives or whatever the name of the
company is right and just like you
probably did that for your checking
account already and but you need to file
your quarterly estimates on that to make
sure you don't end up with any penalties
and if you need some help with that you
can go to one of our endorsed local
providers that do taxes ELP for taxes at
Dave Ramsey comm on the front page there
they'll help you do that part but it
sounds like you've really got this on
the way and the next questions I'd start
asking myself for two things immediately
one is how can I sell more of these
knives out and two how can i produce
more of these knives if I do sell more
and then three how can I you know
continue to grow the viewership on this
YouTube channel how has it grown so far
and how can we add fuel to that fire
what kind of moves can I make to to
maybe get some other youtubers to
feature you or something like that if
there's some gamers that do some
youtubing or something maybe they'd be
there maybe they'd think it's cool that
you're using a knife from the games and
you can jump in and do some of those
kinds of things just try to get the more
momentum on the growth curve of your
youtube viewership is what I would be
trying to do and so you know that's kind
of the marketing side and then the other
side's the production side and the sales
side on the knives themselves you need
to figure out okay this is the price
point I want to produce you want to
produce four hundred fifty dollar knives
$150 now that's a pretty broad spectrum
and your market probably changed the
buyer probably changed between those two
I would guess I'm guessing the customer
of a $450 knife is different than one
from $150 mine might not always be true
but I'm guessing that might be true I
start to study that think about that and
how I can you know how how can we grow
this business and then the next step of
course is if your production gets up
you're probably going to move out of the
apartment and rent
home that has a garage in it that you
can do more production in that there
probably be your next phase of this
process unless I'm wrong so good
question man and congratulations on your
success very proud of you hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show